I'm sending it in a urine sample next week at the moment. I am not on an antibiotic
for a minor UTI. Should I stop the antibiotic before sending it in the urine sample?
No, no. So if you're doing a urine, it depends on what you're doing the urine sample for. So if you're
doing a urine sample, um, well, I'm trying to think of what a person would, what a test urine sample test
would make a difference if you're doing, if you're on an antibiotic and I don't think there is
any. So even if you're doing a urine sample to test for a UTI, um, you still wouldn't stop an
antibiotic because you're doing the antibiotic for a minor UTI. So you're trying to kill any bacteria
into there. So no, no, no, no. You don't have to, you don't have to stop the urine. You don't have
to stop the antibiotic for the urine sample for a microtox test, nor do you have to stop it for
urine sample for a glyphosate test. If that's what you're doing, if it's the test that we sent you,
then no, just do it. You do it tomorrow if you can, or whatever. Do it. The earliest
convenience would be better. The antibiotic should not interfere with that.